[Music]
there may be a million ways to die in
the West but these are our hundred ways
to die in movies exploding from alien
disintegration ray alien parasite
infection exploding can be lit on fire
fiery handshake electrocution rocket
launcher torpedo gasoline bomb remote
bomb grenade nuclear bomb shot on a wall
with an arrow as a singing telegram in
the beds in the snow in the head in the
chest in a dual happiness come by a
booby-trapped shotgun by grenade
launcher by a bullet in slow motion by a
slow motion boy accidentally in the face
beheaded by an axe one source to source
a samurai sword a machete a giant
swinging statue of a lion's head crushed
by a garage door a falling car a boulder
a giant block of ice driving a car off
the first driving a train off the tracks
run over by a board a pickup truck Axel
Foley on a family sedan falling into a
big hole through a window off the low
building off a medium build off a high
building onto a glass table onto a tall
eaten by a giant snake a tiny vampire a
tiny zombie horde of zombies a dinosaur
- dinosaur giant mutant slugs a killer
shark a flock of birds mutants wolves
bugs stabbed with a screwdriver with a
throwing knife with a hatchet with
scissors with the pitchfork in the
shower in the face underwater in the
shoulder by the most handsome man alive
in the heart in the bat in the eyeball
with a bone in the eyeball with a pen
poison sir in head crushed by a bone
club head crushed in a car head crushed
in a head crushing device drowning in a
lake drowning in the pool drowning in
the bathtub
having your eyeballs ripped out by a
gorilla malfunctioning a new chair Avada
Kedavra spell 5-point pom exploding
heart technique bastard death by angry
kids faster death by a bowling - to
death by a monster town alien sinkhole
alien cotton candy Raygun
Yemi choking on food choked by a clown
head up by wire smothered by The
Creature from the Black Lagoon melting
from the inside out melting from the
outside it melting from a bucket of lava
thrown by your evil possessed wife
having your lifeforce sucked out by an
alien intent of infiltrating humanity by
reproduction these were our hundred ways
to die in movies comment below and let
us know what your favorite
[Music]